From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. This all started with a phone call, a call that eventually led to this episode. So that's where I'm going to start. I was talking to a journalist in Gaza on the phone.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》。我是 Chana Joffe-Walt，代替 Ira Glass 主持节目。这一切始于一通电话，正是这通电话促成了这期节目。所以，我想从这里开始讲起。我当时正在和加沙的一位记者通话。
Hello?
喂？
Hi, this is Chana. Hi.
你好，我是 Chana。你好。
How are you?
你好吗？
This was back in April. I'd been speaking to people in Gaza for months by then, but nobody where Maram was, in the middle area, Deir Balah. Maram Hamaid, she's a reporter for Al Jazeera English. We were chatting. I was asking some pretty basic questions about what she was experiencing, what she was seeing, what the day had been like. She got interrupted.
那是四月份的事。到那时为止，我已经和加沙的人们交谈了几个月，但没人像 Maram 那样住在加沙中部代尔拜拉赫（Deir Balah）。Maram Hamaid 是半岛电视台英语频道的记者。我们当时在聊天。我问了一些关于她的经历、所见所闻以及一天过得如何的基础问题。她被中途打断了。
It was a little bit calm day in Deir Balah. You know, like--
代尔拜拉赫今天还算平静。你知道，就像——
Who is it, Mom?
妈妈，是谁呀？
So Banias is listening. I need to introduce Banias to you.
Banias 正在听。我得给你介绍一下 Banias。
Hi, Banias.
你好，Banias。
Hi.
你好。
How are you?
你好吗？
I'm fine, thank you.
我很好，谢谢。
Good.
很好。
Maram and I kept talking-- or trying to.
我和 Maram 继续交谈——或者说尝试交谈。
And you're in Deir Balah? Are you in Deir Balah?
你是在代尔拜拉赫吗？你现在在代尔拜拉赫吗？
Now what do I do?
现在我该怎么办？
Yeah, we are in Deir Balah--
是啊，我们在代尔拜拉赫——
Mom--
妈妈——
--in the central area.
——在中部地区。
--now what do I do?
——现在我该怎么办？
Is that where you're from? Is that where your home is, or did you--
那是你的家乡吗？你是住在自己家，还是……
Uh, no. I'm displaced.
呃，不。我是流离失所者。
Yeah.
是啊。
And we're living in our relative's home here, with around 80 other family members.
我们住在这里的亲戚家里，和大约 80 位家庭成员挤在一起。
Wow.
天哪。
"Ay-dee"!
“Ay-dee”！
Yeah.
是啊。
It's "ay-dee," not "ay-tee." Not "ay-tee."
是“Ay-dee”，不是“Ay-tee”。不是“Ay-tee”。
That's a lot of people.
那人可真多。
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Like a big number--
是啊，是啊，是啊。人数非常多——
Mom, it's "ay-dee," not "ay-tee."
妈妈，是“Ay-dee”，不是“Ay-tee”。
So Banias is correcting me regarding the American accent, OK? So she's saying, like, what is it? It's "ay-tee" or "ay-dee"?
所以 Banias 正在纠正我的美国口音，对吧？她是在说……是哪个词？是“Ay-tee”还是“Ay-dee”？
"Ay-dee"!
“Ay-dee”！
Oh.
哦。
"Ay-dee." "Ay-dee."
“Ay-dee”。“Ay-dee”。
Does she correct you a lot?
她经常纠正你吗？
Yeah! A lot, a lot. She speaks English better than me because I started with her from very young.
会！经常，经常。她的英语比我好，因为她很小的时候我就开始教她了。
Back to me.
回到我这里。
I'm here around Banias--
我在这里陪着 Banias——
Back to me.
回到我这里。
Back to me. [LAUGHS] Yeah.
回到我这里。[笑] 是的。
And where--
那——
She's-- yeah.
她是——是的。
Does she want to talk?
她想说话吗？
Yeah.
想的。
Yeah, I'm pretty ready. I'm ready, ready.
是的，我已经准备好了。我准备好了，真的准备好了。
You're ready, ready. How old are you, Banias?
你准备好了，真的准备好了。Banias，你几岁了？
I'm eight years old.
我今年八岁。
You're eight years old. And where did you learn to speak like an American?
你今年八岁。你是从哪里学会像美国人那样说话的？
From Mama.
从妈妈那里。
Uh-huh. She speaks to you in English?
嗯哼。她用英语和你交流吗？
Yeah. Do you hear that? Do you hear that wee-wee-wee?
是啊。你听到了吗？你听到那个呼呼呼的声音了吗？
I do. Yeah. What is it?
听到了。是的，那是什么？
So Banias is-- [SIGHS] what is it?
Banias 正——[叹气] 那是什么？
It's the whoosh, whoosh, whoosh. A war plane.
那是呼啸声，呼啸声，呼啸声。是战机。
It's a warplane. I do hear it, yeah.
是战机。我确实听到了，是的。
I, of course, hear it, because it never ends.
我当然听得见，因为它从没停过。
Banias then takes the phone from her mom-- having told me what they are hearing, begins pointing out what they're seeing, saying, look at this-- as if I can also see, even though we're not on a video call. She says, here we have the window, as you can see. Here's the curtains. There are flowers. We don't have any sofas, just-- Mom, how do you say it?
Banias 随后从她妈妈手中接过电话——在告诉我他们听到了什么之后，她开始指出他们所看到的一切，说，看这个——就好像我也能看到一样，尽管我们并没有在进行视频通话。她说，正如你所见，这里有窗户。这里是窗帘。那里有花。我们没有任何沙发，只有——妈妈，那个词怎么说？
Mattresses?
床垫？
Just "may-tresses," as you can see. We sit sometimes on bed, on the ground. Women are covering their heads all the time, as you can see.
正如你所见，只有“床垫”。我们有时坐在床上，有时坐在地上。正如你所见，女人们一直用头巾遮住头。
[LAUGHS] She couldn't see. You should tell her.
[笑] 她看不到的。你应该告诉她。
Yeah, tell me.
是啊，告诉我吧。
OK. Oh, did you see our room?
好的。哦，你看到我们的房间了吗？
No.
没有。
If you see it, you will-- you will run, run, run, run from this.
如果你看到它，你肯定会——你肯定会从这里逃跑，跑啊跑啊跑啊。
Why?
为什么？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Because it's so old and dusty.
因为它太老旧、太脏了。
Maram told me later she was so surprised at Banias's performance in this call. That was the word she used. Apparently, Banias was marching around with the phone in front of her, telling people, I need the room, please, jumping on the mattress, standing on the table, pointing, saying, here's my brother, Iyas.
Maram 后来告诉我，她对 Banias 在这次通话中的表现感到非常惊讶。这就是她用的词。显然，Banias 拿着手机在她面前走来走去，对周围的人说，请给我留点空间，在床垫上跳来跳去，站在桌子上，指着说，这是我的弟弟 Iyas。
There he is. He's pretty and smart like me.
看，那就是他。他和一样我漂亮聪明。
Gaza is full of kids. About half the population is under 18 years old, and about half of that group is under 10 years old, like Banias. A huge way in which children in this war are different from kids in other war zones is that children in Gaza are not allowed to leave. They're not displaced to some other spot away from the fighting. They're displaced inside Gaza. They're stuck in the violence and stuck with their families, in crowded rooms or tents, doing the things that kids everywhere do, building their inner world, trying to make sense of the world around them. I was calling Maram that day to ask about the situation in Deir Balah, and Banias took the phone and said, no, no, no, don't ask her. Ask me.
加沙到处都是孩子。大约一半的人口在 18 岁以下，而其中约一半在 10 岁以下，就像 Banias 一样。这场战争中的孩子们与其他战区的孩子最大的不同在于，加沙的孩子们不被允许离开。他们并没有被转移到远离战火的其他地方，而是被困在加沙内部。他们被困在暴力之中，与家人挤在狭窄的房间或帐篷里，做着世界各地孩子都会做的事——建立自己的内心世界，试图理解周围的世界。那天我打电话给 Maram 询问代尔拜拉赫的情况，Banias 抢过电话说，不，不，不，不要问她。问我。
Being in Deir a Balah is boring.
待在代尔拜拉赫很无聊。
It's boring?
很无聊吗？
Really boring.
非常无聊。
Yeah.
是啊。
Not just-- bored, so bored. I really miss the burgers. And now we are on canned food. We have just the boxes of food, the food boxes. One day-- I want to tell you something.
不仅仅是……无聊，太无聊了。我真的很想念汉堡。现在我们只能吃罐头食品。我们只有食品盒，那些食品盒。有一天——我想告诉你一件事。
Tell me.
告诉我。
One day, when we are sitting in our room talking about something, then boom! A big bomb broke all of the windows, and the home was shaking. And my baby brother, Iyas, has got injured in his head. We have noticed the glass in his head.
有一天，当我们坐在房间里聊天时，突然“砰”的一声！一颗巨大的炸弹震碎了所有的窗户，房子都在摇晃。我的弟弟 Iyas 的头部受伤了。我们注意到他头上有玻璃碎片。
Oof. Is he OK, Banias?
天哪。他没事吧，Banias？
Yes, now he's all right.
是的，他现在没事了。
We talked for a while and then said goodbye. That was the end of April. And then, in July, I saw Maram's name on my phone.
我们聊了一会儿便说了再见。那是四月底。到了七月，我在手机上看到了 Maram 的名字。
Hi. Maram? Can you hear me? Hello?
喂？Maram？你能听到吗？喂？
Yeah.
在呢。
It was Banias. She wanted to talk, tell me about her day. Then, another day.
是 Banias。她想和我聊天，告诉我她的一天。然后，又过了几天。
Hello.
喂。
Hi, Banias.
你好，Banias。
Do you want to talk to me?
你想和我聊天吗？
Yeah, sure. What are you doing?
当然。你在做什么？
Through the summer, into the fall, Banias called me, and I called her. Maram, her mother, gave permission for these phone calls, but it was always just Banias on the line, telling me about herself and her life. I wanted to know what it's like to be a kid in this war. And here was this kid who wanted to talk.
整个夏天，一直到秋天，Banias 不时打电话给我，我也打给她。她的母亲 Maram 允许进行这些通话，但每次线上都只有 Banias，向我诉说关于她自己和生活的一切。我想知道作为一个孩子身处这场战争中是什么感觉。而这里有一个渴望交流的孩子。
Banias was a natural narrator of her own life. She was constantly directing my attention. These are my friends. This is my school stationery, as you can see. Do you want to know what we're doing right now? I'll tell you.
Banias 是自己生活的天生叙述者。她不断引导我的注意力。这是我的朋友们。正如你所见，这是我的学校文具。你想知道我们现在在做什么吗？我告诉你。
Unfortunately for me, she also had zero interest in satisfying my journalistic agenda. If I asked Banias a question she was not interested in, she'd yawn dramatically, stage yawn. [YAWNS] It's getting late. I'm so tired. Let's look over here.
不幸的是，她对我那些所谓的新闻访谈议程毫无兴趣。如果我问了 Banias 一个她不感兴趣的问题，她会夸张地打哈欠。[打哈欠] 天色晚了。我好累。我们看那边吧。
I had been reading and thinking about what was happening in Gaza all the time, talking to people there. Every call with Banias was something I hadn't heard that was completely different from when adults tell the story.
我一直在阅读和思考加沙发生的一切，也一直与那边的人交谈。与 Banias 的每一次通话都让我听到了一些从未听过的、与成年人讲述的版本完全不同的故事。
So that is today's episode. We're calling it "The Narrator." We're going to listen to this kid in Gaza, a narrator who does not ask permission to narrate. She takes the phone with a soaring confidence that what she has to tell you is interesting and important, and I agree with her. Stay with us.
这就是今天的主题。我们将其命名为《叙述者》。我们将倾听加沙这个孩子的声音，她是一位不需要征得许可便开始叙述的叙述者。她怀着极度的自信拿起电话，认为她所讲述的内容既有趣又重要，我同意她的看法。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. My calls with Banias were sporadic. Sometimes we talked once a week. Sometimes a month would go by. Usually, we talked at the end of the day, her time, while she was sitting on a mattress inside the house, fidgeting. There were always lots of people and activity in the background, but Banias never explained much about who was there or what they were doing. She told me about what she was doing, what she wanted me to know and sometimes see.
这里是《美国生活》。我和 Banias 的通话断断续续。有时我们一周谈一次，有时一个月过去都没有联络。通常我们是在她那边的傍晚通话，那时她正坐在房里的床垫上，坐立不安。背景里总是有很多人和嘈杂的声音，但 Banias 从未多加解释那些人是谁或在做什么。她只会告诉我她在做什么，她想让我知道，有时甚至想让我看什么。
I prefer a video call.
我更喜欢视频通话。
[BEEPING]
[提示音]
Let me try.
我试一下。
OK.
好的。
Hi.
你好。
This is my complete look.
这就是我的完整造型。
That's a good look.
很棒的造型。
She's in a pink shirt that says "Dream." Huge eyes, dark hair, and pigtails with two loose curls very purposefully framing her face.
她穿着一件印有“Dream”（梦想）字样的粉色衬衫。大眼睛，黑色的头发，两条松散的卷发非常有目的地衬托着她的脸庞。
And you have earrings. I didn't know you had earrings.
你还戴了耳环。我不知道你有耳环。
Oh, yeah, I do have earrings. And this is my blue shorts.
哦，是的，我有耳环。这是我的蓝色短裤。
Yeah.
是啊。
And this, this is my head accessory for today. It has rhinestones.
还有这个，这是我今天的头饰。上面有水钻。
Uh-huh. Purple, furry with rhinestones.
嗯哼。紫色的，毛茸茸的，上面镶着水钻。
Yeah, it's beautiful.
是啊，很漂亮。
When Banias and I first started talking on the phone, my questions were pretty basic. What do you do all day? She was in a house with 80 people, which is unusual in Gaza right now to live in a house. Most people are in tents or schools or other temporary shelters. Banias and her mom, dad, and baby brother were on the ground floor of this house, sharing that floor with about 20 relatives. There was one bedroom.
当我和 Banias 开始通电话时，我的问题都很基础。你整天都在做什么？她当时住在一间有 80 个人的房子里，这在目前的加沙是不常见的。大多数人都住在帐篷、学校或其他临时避难所里。Banias 和她的父母及弟弟住在房子的底层，与大约 20 位亲戚共用这层空间。只有一个卧室。
She slept on a mattress on the floor, alongside her parents, brother, grandpa, uncle, and aunt. Everyone else slept in the living area. If Banias wanted any time in the tiny bathroom, she got up early in the morning. Then she ate breakfast. And then what?
她和父母、弟弟、祖父、叔叔和阿姨一起睡在地板上的床垫上。其他人都睡在起居区。如果 Banias 想在那个狭小的浴室里待一会儿，她得一大早起床。然后吃早餐。接着做什么呢？
Today we play school games.
今天我们玩学校游戏。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
We're pretending that we're in the school. I was a student. And one of my friends was the teacher.
我们假装在学校。我是一个学生。我的一个朋友是老师。
What classes were you taking?
你们在上什么课？
Math class.
数学课。
OK. And did you write actual math, or is it just pretend?
好的。你们是真的在写数学题，还是假装的？
It was actual, the plus and the minus and the equal. It was actual. But it was in a game, not real.
是真的，有加法、减法和等号。是真的在做题。但这只是个游戏，不是真的上学。
At this point, July, Banias had not been in an actual class in an actual school building for nine months. But she played school every day with three other girls, two younger and one older. There were other kids in the building, but everyone else was just OK, or a boy, or a baby.
此时是七月，Banias 已经九个月没有在真正的教学楼里上过真正的课了。但她每天都和另外三个女孩一起玩“学校游戏”，两个比她小，一个比她大。楼里还有其他孩子，但其他人要么只是还行，要么是男孩，要么是婴儿。
When aid organizations go into other war zones, one of the first things they do for kids is set up schools, because children need a sense of routine and a sense that life is moving forward toward a future. There's no safe place in Gaza to set up schools like that, so Banias and her friends in the building created that for themselves. They played school for hours. There were lectures. There were assignments. There were exams.
当援助组织进入其他战区时，他们为孩子做的第一件事就是建立学校，因为孩子们需要一种日常感，需要一种生活正在向前、通往未来的感觉。在加沙没有安全的地方建立这样的学校，所以 Banias 和她在楼里的朋友们为自己创造了这样的环境。她们玩了好几个小时的学校游戏。有讲座，有作业，还有考试。
Who is usually in charge of what you're going to do that day?
通常谁负责决定你们当天要做什么？
The girl that's older than me. Her name is Dana.
那个比我大的女孩。她叫 Dana。
How old is Dana?
Dana 多大了？
She is 12 years old. And she has an iPad.
她 12 岁了。她有一台 iPad。
Dana is generous with her iPad. So this is another part of Banias's day-- games on the iPad. When the war started, her mother's screen time rules went out the window. But also, Israel cut off electricity to Gaza. There's just generators and solar panels, so screen time is limited anyway.
Dana 对她的 iPad 很慷慨。所以这是 Banias 日常生活的另一部分——玩 iPad 游戏。战争开始时，她妈妈对屏幕时间的限制就不复存在了。但同时，以色列切断了加沙的电力。只有发电机和太阳能电池板，所以屏幕使用时间无论如何都很有限。
And today, we played a cafe game.
今天，我们玩了咖啡馆游戏。
Oh, a cafe? That's new.
哦，咖啡馆？那是新花样。
I was the chef. Yeah. And one of my friends was the customer. I cooked some salad and some pancake.
我是厨师。是的。我的一个朋友是顾客。我做了一些沙拉和煎饼。
Say it one more time?
再说一遍？
I cooked salad and pancake. And I made some hamburgers and some pizza.
我做了沙拉和煎饼。我还做了汉堡和披萨。
Banias was re-enacting her old life, where she had teachers and exams and went out to cafes. There was one they used to go to every Saturday.
Banias 正在重温她的旧生活，那时候她有老师，有考试，还会去咖啡馆。他们以前每周六都会去一家咖啡馆。
Yeah, it was really close. It was just in the next street in our house.
是的，离我们很近。就在我们房子旁边的下一条街上。
OK. Did they make salad and pancakes?
好的。他们卖沙拉和煎饼吗？
No, but I used to order some noodles and some hot chocolate.
不，但我以前常点面条和热巧克力。
Mm-hmm. What did you eat in real life today?
嗯哼。你今天现实中吃了什么？
Today we have eaten some beans, some white beans.
今天我们吃了一些豆子，白豆。
Do you ever get to eat pancakes or noodles or burgers?
你有时能吃到煎饼、面条或汉堡吗？
I hate pancakes and noodles.
我讨厌煎饼和面条。
You do?
真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
Oh, wow.
哦，天哪。
Do you believe somebody hates these things?
你相信有人会讨厌这些东西吗？
No.
不信。
I do.
我就讨厌。
They're so good.
它们明明那么好吃。
But I hate them.
但我就是讨厌它们。
I was never sure what motivated Banias to want to talk to me. She seemed to like telling me about her day, practicing her English. She had an ongoing fascination with the time difference between us. She always wanted to check in on that.
我一直不确定是什么动力让 Banias 想和我说话。她似乎很喜欢告诉我她的一天，练习她的英语。她对我们之间的时间差一直很着迷。她总是想确认这一点。
You're at morning or at night?
你是早上还是晚上？
It's the afternoon. It's just--
现在是下午。只是——
Afternoon?
下午？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
We're in the middle of the night.
我们这里是半夜。
She'd call when she felt annoyed that Dana got to be the teacher that day yet again.
当她因为 Dana 那天又当了老师而感到烦恼时，她会打电话给我。
I am bored of being the student every day. I'm the oldest. I should be the teacher. Oof!
我厌倦了每天都当学生。我是最大的，我应该当老师。哎！
And she'd call when she was bored. She'd call because I was an adult who would pay attention to her. Banias had to create activity-- interest-- out of such little material. Sometimes I got the impression I was there to help with that. Like, one night she was on the phone with me, and another phone rang. And like a character in a play, she went, oh, look, the phone is ringing.
她也会在感到无聊时打电话给我。她会打来是因为我是一个会关注她的成年人。Banias 必须从极其有限的素材中创造出活动和趣味。有时我觉得我的存在就是为了帮助她实现这一点。比如，有一天她正在和我通话时，另一部电话响了。她就像戏里的角色一样说，哦，看，电话响了。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话响声]
Oh, my God. Who's ringing the phone? Get away. Get lost.
天哪。是谁在打电话？走开。滚远点。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
We have to sleep.
我们要睡觉了。
You're pretty funny, Banias.
你真幽默，Banias。
Yes, I'm funny. Dana always say for me that I'm a bit funny.
是的，我很幽默。Dana 总说我很有趣。
Really?
真的吗？
Funny bunny.
趣萌兔。
Mm-hmm. You are funny.
嗯哼。你确实很有趣。
Yes. I'm a funny bunny.
是的。我是一只趣萌兔。
So Banias had her own reasons to call me. When I called her, it was for different reasons. I'd call her because I'd read about a bombing campaign or fighting near where she was. Was she OK? And what was she thinking about all the violence around her? What is this like for an eight-year-old?
所以 Banias 有她自己的理由打电话给我。而我打给她，是出于不同的原因。我会打给她是因为我读到了关于她所在地区附近的轰炸或冲突的新闻。她还好吗？对于周围所有的暴力，她是怎么想的？这对一个八岁的孩子来说意味着什么？
In the middle of the summer, there was a series of intense airstrikes near Banias. I was curious if she'd heard them or seen them, but I also wanted to follow her lead and what she wanted to talk about.
在夏天的中期，Banias 附近发生了一系列剧烈的空袭。我很好奇她是否听到了或看到了，但我同时也想顺着她的思路，关注她想谈论的话题。
Do you have some time to talk?
你有时间聊聊吗？
Oh, yes, of course. I'm available.
哦，当然，我有空。
Great.
太好了。
I'm actually good.
我其实挺好的。
Yeah?
是吗？
Doing good. Last days, we have heard a bit of bombing around us.
做得不错。最近几天，我们听到附近有一些爆炸声。
Uh-huh. Yeah, I've been reading in the news that there's been a lot of bombing.
嗯哼。是的，我在新闻里读到那里有很多轰炸。
Yeah, I do know. It was loud.
我知道。声音很大。
Is it scary?
这可怕吗？
No. For me, no. Me and my friends, we were playing hide-and-seek. We don't ever get bored of it. It's our favorite game. When we are playing, some strange things happens with us. I will tell you then.
不可怕。对我来说不可怕。我和朋友们在玩捉迷藏。我们永远不会对这游戏感到厌烦。这是我们最喜欢的游戏。当我们玩的时候，会发生一些奇怪的事情。我到时候会告诉你的。
OK, I thought. Here it is. She's about to tell me something big about what it's like to be a kid playing hide-and-seek with bombs going off nearby. Banias told me, so we were playing, and we ran to the backyard.
好的，我想。来了。她要告诉我关于在炮火声中玩捉迷藏的重大感受了。Banias 告诉我，我们当时正在玩，然后跑到了后院。
When we run to the backyard, we see some insects in the ground.
当我们跑进后院时，我们看到地上有一些昆虫。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
We said, we see some insects on the ground. And me and the kids, we watched it.
我们说，我们看到地上有一些昆虫。然后我和孩子们就盯着看。
That's it. That's her whole story. The strange thing that happened when they ran outside is they saw insects, a kind of insect they'd never seen before. Not the bombing-- bugs.
就这样。这就是她的全部故事。她们跑出去时发生的奇怪的事情就是她们看到了一些昆虫，一种她们从未见过的昆虫。不是轰炸，而是虫子。
Children are not known for their sense of scale or the longevity of their attention. And maybe it wasn't surprising that pretty much every time I asked about the war, Banias didn't really want to engage. She didn't exactly ignore me, but it didn't seem to be the main thing she was thinking about.
孩子们并不以衡量尺度或长时间专注而闻名。所以，每当我问起战争时，Banias 并不太想深入讨论，这也就不足为奇了。她没有完全忽略我，但这似乎并不是她心中主要的想法。
Like, when an airstrike broke the windows in her house, she wanted to tell me about a prank she played on Dana. In mid-August, when ceasefire negotiations between Israel and Hamas seemed to be unraveling yet again, and all the adults I was talking to in Gaza were deeply dispirited, here was Banias.
比如，当空袭震碎了她家里的窗户时，她却想告诉我她对 Dana 搞的一个恶作剧。八月中旬，当以色列和哈马斯之间的停火谈判似乎再次破裂时，我在加沙交谈的所有成年人都感到极度沮丧，但 Banias 却是这样。
I think there will be a ceasefire soon.
我想很快就会停火的。
You do? Why do you think that?
你觉得呢？为什么这么想？
Because it's really close to end.
因为它快要结束了。
Why? Why do you say-- what gives you that idea?
为什么？为什么你会这么说——是什么让你有这种想法？
Mom and Dad tell me. [YAWNS]
爸爸妈妈告诉我的。[打哈欠]
I heard that yawn-- noting it. Discussion of the war-- over. There was one moment when Banias was forced to engage. She couldn't avoid it. Banias's family had been sheltering in Deir Balah for almost a year, when, suddenly, at the end of August, they got an evacuation order. Israel posted a map on social media designating certain blocks in Deir Balah unsafe.
我听到那个哈欠了——记下来。关于战争的讨论——到此为止。有一次，Banias 不得不面对现实。她无法回避。Banias 的一家在代尔拜拉赫避难了近一年，这时突然在八月底，他们接到了撤离命令。以色列在社交媒体上发布了一张地图，将代尔拜拉赫的某些区域指定为不安全区域。
And I saw that Maram, Banias's mother, had written something for Al Jazeera about the order. I had hardly spoken to Maram for months, but I had followed her reporting on bombings and food shortages. This article, though, was personal. She wrote about her confusion about what to do next. "I've never felt so worthless as a human being," she wrote.
我看到 Banias 的母亲 Maram 为半岛电视台写了一些关于这个命令的文章。我有好几个月没和 Maram 说上话了，但我一直关注着她关于轰炸和粮食短缺的报道。然而这篇文章非常私人。她写下了她对下一步该做什么的困惑。“作为一个人类，我从未感到如此无用，”她写道。
"A single Facebook post from an Israeli military spokesperson can upend our lives in an instant. Have you ever felt like a toy being played with left and right, east and west, pushed from one place to another, south to Khan Younis, out of Rafah, back to Khan Younis, then to Nuseirat, only to be driven out again? People are literally running through the streets like mad, clutching what little they have left. We have nothing left. Our hearts are broken, and our minds are frayed.
“以色列军方发言人的一条 Facebook 帖子就能瞬间颠覆我们的生活。你有没有感觉自己像一个被玩弄于股掌之间的玩具，被从东到西、从左到右，从一个地方推向另一个地方——向南逃往汗尤尼斯，离开拉法，回到汗尤尼斯，然后去努赛拉特，最后又被驱逐？人们真的像疯了一样在街上奔跑，紧紧抓着他们仅存的一点东西。我们一无所有了。我们的心碎了，精神也崩溃了。”
I look around at the few possessions I've managed to gather over the past 10 months-- a stove, cups, plates, pots, winter clothes, summer clothes, mattresses, blankets, batteries, light bulbs, big bottles of drinking water, tubs to wash clothes in. If I leave everything, there's no way to replace it. There are no markets, no supplies, no money to spare. We're running and running aimlessly. People screaming, suffering, and dying while the world watches," end quote. And then my phone rang.
“我环顾四周，看看过去 10 个月里我设法收集到的几样东西——一个炉子、杯子、盘子、锅、冬装、夏装、床垫、毯子、电池、灯泡、大瓶饮用水、洗衣服的盆。如果我丢下这一切，我就没法再添置了。没有市场，没有补给，没有多余的钱。我们就在那里漫无目的地奔跑。人们在尖叫、受苦、死亡，而世界在注视，”引用结束。接着，我的电话响了。
Hello?
喂？
Hi, Banias.
你好，Banias。
Yeah.
在呢。
Do you want to talk?
想聊聊吗？
Uh, OK. Today, we have done a new thing.
呃，好的。今天我们做了一件新鲜事。
What'd you do?
做了什么？
We drawed some pictures. I imagined that there's a garden, that there's some people walking inside it.
我们画了一些画。我想象有一个花园，有一些人在里面散步。
[CHILD CRYING]
[孩子哭泣声]
Stop crying. Go in the bedroom.
别哭了。去卧室里。
OK.
好的。
So let's continue.
那我们继续。
OK.
好的。
Oh, my friends were with me, too, drawing. And one of my friends have drawed a plane.
哦，我的朋友们也在和我一起画。我的一个朋友画了一架飞机。
Like a war plane or a plane you travel in?
是像战机还是那种旅行的飞机？
Uh, traveling.
呃，旅行的。
OK. Do you ever draw anything about the war?
好的。你画过任何关于战争的东西吗？
No, nothing at all.
没有，一点也没有。
Why not?
为什么不呢？
Because-- I really can't.
因为——我真的不能。
Why?
为什么？
I feel mad.
我感到生气。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
I feel mad of this things. I can draw them. But I don't like a war plane, a helicopter, and rockets. I don't like that. There's lots of things here I feel mad from it. My friends always make me mad from things. Sometimes I don't want anybody to enter this room. Get out. Mom! OK.
我对这些事情感到生气。我可以画它们，但我一点也不喜欢战机、直升机和火箭。我不喜欢这些。这里有很多让我生气的事情。我的朋友们总是因为一些事情让我生气。有时我不想让任何人进入这个房间。出去。妈妈！好的。
I'm sorry.
抱歉。
OK, let's continue.
好的，我们继续。
OK.
好的。
I was saying they always attack me.
我刚才说她们总是攻击我。
Your friends?
你的朋友们？
Yeah.
是的。
I was eager to ask Banias about the news of the evacuation, but what she wanted to talk about was a fight she had that day with another kid in the building, a girl. Banias calls her "the girl with the bad personality." That girl told Banias today that one of her pictures was no good.
我很想问 Banias 关于撤离命令的新闻，但她想聊的却是那天她和楼里另一个孩子——一个女孩——之间的争执。Banias 称她为“那个性格坏的女孩”。那个女孩今天告诉 Banias，她的画画得不好。
She have a really bad personality. I said for her, are you looking for a fight, in our language.
她的性格真的很差。我用我们的语言对她说，你是想打架吗？
And what did she say?
她说什么？
Yes, I am.
是的，我是。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And we fighted all day. She's the most bad friend.
我们就这样打了一整天。她是最坏的朋友。
Did she not know about the evacuation order? She must, right? I didn't want to scare her.
难道她不知道撤离命令吗？她肯定知道，对吧？我不想吓到她。
Banias, I saw your mom wrote about people leaving Deir Balah.
Banias，我看到你妈妈写关于人们离开代尔拜拉赫的事情了。
Yes.
是的。
Have you--
你有没有——
But we will go to Al-Zawayda, to our relatives.
但我们会去 Al-Zawayda，去我们的亲戚那里。
What do you think about that?
你怎么想？
I think it was a good idea. We're packing our clothes and our-- wait for a minute. [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Oh, and we're packing also our mattresses and our money.
我觉得这是个好主意。我们正在打包衣服和我们的……等一下。[非英语对话] 哦，我们还在打包床垫和钱。
Where will you sleep if you pack your mattress?
如果你打包了床垫，你们睡哪里？
Um, in the tent. Our relatives live in a home. But we will make a camp next to them.
嗯，在帐篷里。我们的亲戚住在房子里，但我们会在他们旁边搭个营地。
OK. Have you ever lived in a tent?
好的。你以前住过帐篷吗？
No.
没有。
Are you--
你是——
But I want to try. I think it will be something creative.
但我很想试试。我想那会很有创意。
Are you scared to move, to leave your friends or to leave your house?
你害怕搬家，离开你的朋友或房子吗？
I'm ready to leave them.
我已经准备好离开她们了。
You are? [CHUCKLES]
是吗？[轻笑]
I'm not ready for more fights. I want to leave them. Today, I told one of my friends that I will leave. I've told everybody.
我不想再打架了。我想离开她们。今天，我告诉其中一个朋友我要走了。我告诉了所有人。
Is that sad?
那令人难过吗？
It was drama.
那简直是一场闹剧。
Why?
为什么？
Because she is a drama girl. Don't leave. That's everything.
因为她是个爱闹剧的女孩。别走。就是这样。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Don't leave this house. We want more fights.
别离开这房子。我们还要再打架呢。
Banias was ready to leave because it meant she could get away from the girl with the bad personality. Almost a million kids in Gaza have made a move like this since Israel invaded, many of them multiple times. So it was interesting to hear how a child was thinking about it.
Banias 准备离开，因为这意味着她可以远离那个性格糟糕的女孩。自从以色列入侵以来，加沙有近一百万孩子像这样搬过家，很多人还是多次搬迁。所以听听一个孩子对此的思考很有趣。
Banias was ready to flee the home she'd lived in for 10 months at that point, to move into a tent because she got into a fight with an annoying girl that day, because that is what just happened-- and because Banias is eight. She told me her friend Dana is leaving, too.
Banias 准备逃离她住了 10 个月的家，搬进帐篷，仅仅是因为她那天和一个讨厌的女孩打了一架——因为这就是刚刚发生的事——也因为 Banias 才八岁。她告诉我她的朋友 Dana 也要走了。
She is going to Al Mawasi. But me, I will go to Zawayda, me and my family. Yeah, our relatives are there. When the Israeli army tell us to move, we'll move to Al Zawayda.
她要去 Al Mawasi。但我，我会去 Zawayda，我和我的家人。是的，我们的亲戚在那边。当以色列军队叫我们离开时，我们会搬到 Al Zawayda。
You're not scared?
你不害怕吗？
[YAWNS] No.
[打哈欠] 不怕。
OK.
好的。
[INAUDIBLE] crying and he was praying.
[听不清] 哭着，他当时正在祈祷。
Mom, let that a secret!
妈妈，让那成为秘密！
No, it's not a secret. You have to express yourself.
不，这不是秘密。你必须表达你的感受。
I'm fine, I'm fine.
我没事，我没事。
What does your mom think is a secret?
你妈妈认为什么是秘密？
Uh-- a family secret. No. No. I will not give you the mobile. I want to talk to her myself. No, [INAUDIBLE]. No, no.
呃——一个家庭秘密。不。不。我不给你手机了。我想亲自和她谈。不，[听不清]。不，不。
Is that Chana?
是 Chana 吗？
Hi.
你好。
Hi. How are you?
你好。你好吗？
Good.
很好。
No, no! Let that away! Let that away! Let that away!
不，不！把那个拿走！拿走！拿走！
I was just--
我只是——
No, no! Let that away.
不，不！拿走。
--I just heard her--
——我刚才听到她——
Please, please!
拜托，拜托！
--saying that--
——说那个——
Not here!
不要在这！
Your--
你的——
So Banias was crying.
所以 Banias 在哭。
No! Can you keep that away?
不！你能把那个拿走吗？
It's normal.
这很正常。
It's a secret. I don't want--
这是个秘密。我不想——
This is normal.
这很正常。
I don't want to let anybody know that I was-- I wasn't!
我不想让任何人知道我当时——我没哭！
No.
不。
No, I was--
不，我是——
You were crying.
你在哭。
--I wasn't!
——我没哭！
So she was afraid. She was nervous. And she went into--
所以她很害怕。她很紧张。她进入了一个——
I was not afraid!
我没害怕！
--a circle--
——循环——
I was not nervous!
我不紧张！
--of feeling sad and feeling nervous--
——感到难过和紧张的循环——
[INAUDIBLE] Keep that away!
[听不清] 把那个拿走！
--very afraid of what is going on. And I just surprisingly heard her saying that I'm not.
——非常害怕正在发生的事情。而我居然惊讶地听到她说她没有。
Let that away!
把那个拿走！
I didn't feel afraid.
我没感到害怕。
Let that away!
把那个拿走！
Why? Why does she not want to talk about that?
为什么？为什么她不想谈论那个？
And she's now saying that it's a secret. Like, she doesn't want to recall some horrific memories for her, or like she got over the feeling of being afraid.
现在她说这是个秘密。就好像她不想回忆起那些恐怖的记忆，或者好像她已经克服了那种恐惧感。
When did she find out you were evacuating?
她是什么时候知道你们要撤离的？
Excuse me?
对不起？
I didn't cry!
我没哭！
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
I didn't cry!
我没哭！
Hallas, she believes you. She believes you. She believes you. I know. Like, you're a brave girl. Like, you can get over anything. But I'm telling you, Banias. It's not a shame. It's not a shameful thing to feel afraid that you're scared and you're afraid of something like this. Yeah? So--
好啦，她相信你。她相信你。她相信你。我知道。你是勇敢的女孩。你能克服任何困难。但我告诉你，Banias，这并不羞耻。对于感到害怕、对于这种事感到恐惧并不是什么可耻的事。是吧？所以——
So--
所以——
--right? It's normal. You should be scared. Yeah, this is very normal.
——对吧？这很正常。你应该感到害怕。是的，这非常正常。
I was not--
我没——
And do what I can.
尽我所能。
--scared!
——害怕！
OK, Mama, you are hallas. You are afraid to say what you want. But I want to just to clarify this point. [LAUGHS] You were crying like crazy upon hearing the news. And I'm telling her, like I totally understand her feelings.
好的，妈妈，好啦。你不敢说你想说的话。但我只想澄清这一点。[笑] 你听到消息时哭得稀里哗啦。我告诉她，我完全理解她的感受。
When did that happen, Maram? When did you tell her?
那是什么时候发生的，Maram？你是什么时候告诉她的？
It's just less than two hours ago.
就在不到两小时前。
Oh, wow, just recently. OK. OK.
哦，天哪，就在刚才。好的。好的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Very recent, you know? Very recent. We got the news suddenly. [LAUGHS] I was really laughing when I heard her trying to show a perfectionist reaction and so positive. She was very positive.
是啊，是啊，是啊。非常近，你知道吗？非常近。我们突然收到了消息。[笑] 我听到她试图表现出完美主义者的反应，表现得非常积极时，真的笑了。她非常乐观。
But it was totally the opposite, you know? Just, like, two hours, less than two hours, she was hiding behind the curtain, crying and like crazy. And she continued this cycle. And then we find it's really hard.
但事实完全相反，你知道吗？就在不到两小时前，她躲在窗帘后面，哭得像疯了一样。她不断陷入这种循环。然后我们发现这真的很难。
I almost couldn't bear hearing this. Banias's visceral, immediate panic was so uncomfortable, hearing her mother pierce the carefully constructed artifice she'd presented to me. And it was disorienting. It made me think of all the things I didn't know.
我几乎无法忍受听到这些。Banias 发自肺腑、直接的恐慌让人如此不安，听到她母亲撕开了她在我面前精心构建的虚假外壳。这让人感到迷失方向。这让我想到所有我所不知道的事情。
Does she want to talk again?
她想再谈谈吗？
Yeah, yeah. She's here. She's here.
想的，她在这里。她在这里。
OK.
好的。
[INAUDIBLE] come and [INAUDIBLE]
[听不清] 过来和 [听不清]
Hello?
喂？
Hi, Banias.
你好，Banias。
Hi.
你好。
Hi. How come you didn't want me to know that you were upset?
你好。为什么你不想让我知道你很难过？
I'm not upset.
我不难过。
You're not upset. Do you want to talk about that or no?
你不难过。你想谈谈那个吗，还是不想？
Not yet.
还没到时候。
What?
什么？
Not yet.
还没到时候。
Is there anything else you want to tell me about how you're doing?
还有什么你想告诉我的关于你近况的事情吗？
I'm already so sleepy.
我已经很困了。
Yeah, it's late. So I hope you have an easy night, Banias.
好吧，天色很晚了。希望你有个安稳的夜晚，Banias。
I hope so.
希望如此。
An incomplete list of things Banias does not have control over-- can she go home? No. Is there food? Not enough. Is there school? No. Is there safety here? No. Banias lives in what has become the most dangerous place in the world to be a child.
Banias 无法掌控的事情清单不完全统计——她能回家吗？不能。有食物吗？不够。有学校吗？没有。这里安全吗？没有。Banias 生活在目前世界上对孩子来说最危险的地方。
Disease in Gaza is widespread. Children face acute malnutrition. Kids are getting horrible skin infections. Polio has reappeared in a 10-month-old baby. Children are losing their limbs, their parents, and they are being killed, constantly. More than 13,000 children have been killed so far, including at least 710 babies, some of them born and then killed since the war began.
加沙的疾病十分普遍。孩子们面临严重营养不良。孩子们患上了可怕的皮肤感染。小儿麻痹症在一名 10 个月大的婴儿身上复现了。孩子们正在失去四肢、失去父母，而且他们不断被杀害。到目前为止，超过 13,000 名儿童被杀害，其中包括至少 710 名婴儿，有些婴儿从战争开始就出生然后被杀。
Maram told me Banias has seen dead children. She's seen their small bodies wrapped in white cloth by the hospital. I asked Maram later, what do you think Banias gets out of talking to me? She told me, you're a bubble for her.
Maram 告诉我 Banias 见过死去的孩子。她见过医院里用白布包裹着的小尸体。我后来问 Maram，你觉得 Banias 从与我的通话中得到了什么？她告诉我，你对她来说是一个气泡。
Every time you call, she treats it like an important meeting, tries to find a private space away from all of us. Everyone around Banias is in the midst of this chaos, she said. You're not here. You're not experiencing any of this.
每次你打电话，她都把它当作一次重要的会议，试图找一个远离我们所有人的私密空间。她说，Banias 周围的每个人都身处这片混乱之中。你不在现场。你没有经历这一切。
Banias was telling me a version of life where she has ultimate authority, where she gets to be the narrator. Who doesn't want that? I was coming to her to understand the war, but she was coming to me to not talk about the war, until one day, she did. That's coming up from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
Banias 正在向我讲述一个拥有绝对主权的生活版本，在那里她是叙述者。谁不想要那样呢？我通过她去理解战争，而她通过我来逃避谈论战争，直到有一天，她不得不谈起。这就是我们要带来的内容，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. Our show today, "The Narrator," an eight-year-old in Gaza, tells us about her life in the middle of a war.
这里是《美国生活》。我是 Chana Joffe-Walt，代替 Ira Glass 主持节目。我们今天的节目《叙述者》，加沙的一名八岁孩子，讲述了她在战争中的生活。
This war started in 2023. Hamas attacked Israel, killed about 1,200 people, and took 251 people hostage. Since then, Israel has launched a 14-month ground invasion and bombing campaign in Gaza. More than 44,000 Palestinians have been killed, and more than 13,000 of those dead are children.
这场战争始于 2023 年。哈马斯袭击了以色列，杀害了约 1,200 人，并劫持了 251 人为人质。从那时起，以色列在加沙发动了为期 14 个月的地面入侵和轰炸行动。超过 44,000 名巴勒斯坦人被杀，其中超过 13,000 名死者是儿童。
Banias and her family never moved into a tent. After the Israeli army issued that evacuation order for Deir Balah, her parents agonized over when and if they should flee for days. The dangers of moving into a tent could be worse than tanks outside their house. They decided to stay put. It was early October. The family was coming up on a year of war and displacement, and Banias had an announcement.
Banias 和她的家人从未住进帐篷。在以军针对代尔拜拉赫发布疏散令后，她的父母挣扎了几天，考虑是否以及何时应该逃离。搬进帐篷的危险可能比房屋外的坦克还要严重。他们决定留在原地。那是十月初。这家人即将度过一年的战争与流离失所，而 Banias 有一个重大宣布。
The war stopped. The war stopped. Do you know, the war stopped?
战争停止了。战争停止了。你知道吗，战争停止了？
Yesterday, there was no bombing or fighting?
昨天没有轰炸或战斗了吗？
No. Ever, never. The war stopped.
没有。永远，从来没有。战争停止了。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
Because our house was bombed.
因为我们的房子被炸了。
Your house was bombed?
你们房子被炸了？
Yeah. Just kidding.
是啊。开玩笑的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
But--
但——
What are you doing to me, Banias?
你这是在对我做什么，Banias？
But there was good news yesterday. Yesterday, tonight, it was-- wee! We had a party. There was very, very good news.
但昨天有好消息。昨天，今晚，那是——呜！我们举行了派对。那是非常、非常好的消息。
What was the good news?
什么好消息？
Oh. Um-- we have killed all of them.
哦。嗯——我们杀了他们所有人。
What do you mean? Who did you kill all of?
你是什么意思？你杀了谁的全部？
Not all of them-- thousands and thousands and thousands of them! But I can't remember who.
不是所有人——成千上万，成千上万的人！但我记不清是谁了。
You're talking about the Israelis?
你说的是以色列人？
Yes, yes. Thousands and thousands. We killed thousands, thousands, thousands.
是的，是的。成千上万。我们杀了成千上万，成千上万。
I realized as we were talking, this was October 2. The day before, Iran had launched 180 missiles at Israel.
谈话中我意识到，那天是 10 月 2 日。前一天，伊朗向以色列发射了 180 枚导弹。
That was--
那是——
Yes, that was yesterday. Yesterday, we had a party for that. We bring coffee, make juice. Oh! Kay-yef-nah.
是的，那是昨天。昨天，我们为此举行了派对。我们拿来咖啡，榨果汁。哦！Kay-yef-nah。
Kay-yef-nah?
Kay-yef-nah？
Yes.
是的。
What's "kay-yef-nah" mean?
“Kay-yef-nah”是什么意思？
That means "we had a good time" in Arabic.
那在阿拉伯语里意思是“我们玩得很开心”。
Banias, you're talking about the missiles yesterday to the Israelis?
Banias，你在谈论昨天针对以色列人的导弹？
Yes.
是的。
How did you feel about that?
你对此有什么感觉？
It was-- whoa! It was very good. [NON-ENGLISH]
那是——哇！非常好。[非英语]
This threw me, hearing Banias talk about killing Israelis. No Israelis were killed from these missiles. One Palestinian man was, near Jericho. It's one of those empty truisms about war, that kids in a war learn to hate the other side, a true thing about war that also can feel a little abstract.
听到 Banias 谈论杀害以色列人让我感到震惊。这些导弹并没有炸死任何以色列人。有一名巴勒斯坦男子在杰里科附近遇难。关于战争的一个陈词滥调是，战区的孩子学会仇恨另一方，这是一个关于战争的真实事实，但有时听起来可能有点抽象。
But here it was, showing up, randomly folded into the rest of Banias's narration to her playing with me, messing with me, that the home she was sheltering in was bombed-- which it could have been, but wasn't. I asked Maram if I could talk with her about this day. I told her what Banias had told me.
但它确实出现了，随机地交织在 Banias 对我的叙述中，跟我玩闹、跟我开玩笑说她居住的房子被炸了——虽然那本可能发生，但实际上没有。我问 Maram 我能否和她谈谈这一天。我告诉了她 Banias 跟我说的话。
What was happening that day?
那天发生了什么？
Yeah, actually, on that day, it was a huge surprise, actually. Suddenly, we were at home, and we heard the sounds of cheer and people around us cheering and chanting. The internet was cut.
是的，实际上那天是一个巨大的惊喜。我们当时在家里，突然听到欢呼声，周围的人在欢呼雀跃。互联网断了。
And I thought from the first instance that there was a ceasefire or something like this. The war ended, you know? So people around us started to say that Iran is bombing Israel right now. And we could see the lights of the missiles being sent to Israel, in the sky. And people around us are just cheering and celebrating and clapping.
起初我以为是停火之类的。战争结束了，你知道吗？周围的人开始说伊朗现在正在轰炸以色列。我们能看到导弹射向以色列的火光，就在天空中。周围的人只是在欢呼、庆祝和鼓掌。
I was in emotion. I was very emotional. I really cried. I felt like, oh, my God, really? Someone who's trying just to stop Israel, and to say that by the missiles and by the rockets, the same language that Israel understands and uses in Gaza throughout the years.
我当时情绪很激动。我真的哭了。我感觉，哦，天哪，真的吗？有人正在试图阻止以色列，并说通过导弹和火箭，用以色列多年来在加沙理解和使用的同一种语言。
Were you celebrating? Were you guys celebrating?
你在庆祝吗？你们在庆祝吗？
I didn't. We were just like excited. We stayed home because maybe missiles could drop by mistake on us. We were just trying to follow up the news.
我没有。我们只是很兴奋。我们留在家里，因为导弹可能会错误地掉在我们头上。我们只是试着追踪新闻。
Maram told me she does not tell Banias to hate Israel or celebrate when Israel is attacked. Banias's dad, she says, also doesn't do this. But Maram was not surprised to hear Banias was saying this. She remembers feeling the same way when she was a kid growing up in Gaza.
Maram 告诉我，她没有教 Banias 去仇恨以色列或在以色列被攻击时庆祝。她说 Banias 的爸爸也不会这样做。但 Maram 并不惊讶听到 Banias 会这么说。她记得自己还是个在加沙长大的孩子时，也有过同样的感觉。
Maram was 10 years old when she first experienced Israeli bombing after the Second Intifada broke out. She remembers crying when she saw her first dead body and collapsing when she saw footage of a 12-year-old Palestinian kid, Mohammed al-Durrah, killed while hiding next to his father. Banias was born in 2016. Her first war was when she was four years old.
Maram 10 岁时第一次在第二次大起义爆发后经历了以色列的轰炸。她记得第一次看到尸体时大哭，看到 12 岁的巴勒斯坦孩子穆罕默德·杜拉在父亲旁边躲藏时被杀的录像时崩溃。Banias 出生于 2016 年。她的第一次战争是在四岁时。
I totally understand that she herself, as a Palestinian kid, she views Israel as an enemy, an enemy that bombs us, that kills us, that targets us.
我完全理解她自己作为一名巴勒斯坦孩子，将以色列视为敌人，一个轰炸我们、杀害我们、针对我们的敌人。
There's something I've been thinking about when it comes to kids in wars, but kids in Gaza in particular. It's something a psychologist told me, Dr. Iman Farajallah, who studies the effect of war and occupation on Palestinian kids. She told me it really gets under her skin when people at the UN or healthcare professionals or whatever say kids in Gaza are suffering from PTSD.
关于战区的孩子，特别是加沙的孩子，我一直在思考一件事。心理学家 Iman Farajallah 博士告诉过我，她研究战争和占领对巴勒斯坦孩子的影响。她说，当联合国的人、医护人员或其他什么人说加沙的孩子患有 PTSD（创伤后应激障碍）时，她非常反感。
Post-traumatic stress means the traumatic event is over. For kids in Gaza, the trauma is continuous. There is no post. There's no opportunity for recovery. Instead, there is just coping. Dr. Farajallah says, you'll see kids cope in all different ways. Some kids act out. Some can't leave their parents' side. Other kids get obsessed with soccer or drawing. Or children try to shape their world in other ways.
“创伤后”意味着创伤事件已经结束。对于加沙的孩子来说，创伤是持续的。没有所谓的“后”。没有恢复的机会。相反，只有应对。Farajallah 博士说，你会看到孩子们用各种不同的方式应对。有的孩子行为反常。有的不能离开父母一步。其他孩子沉迷于足球或绘画。或者孩子们试图用其他方式塑造他们的世界。
For instance, Maram told me when Banias was six years old, there was an Israeli military operation in Gaza, lots of fighting. And Banias was sitting on the window, watching ambulances rush people to the hospital, blowing bubbles out the window. Maram asked her, what are you doing? And Banias said, I'm trying to change the mood.
例如，Maram 告诉我，Banias 六岁时，以色列在加沙进行了一次军事行动，有很多战斗。Banias 当时坐在窗边，看着救护车把人送往医院，对着窗外吹泡泡。Maram 问她，你在做什么？Banias 说，我在尝试改变心情。
I know Banias. She is an optimistic one. She's someone who's positive. And she doesn't even want to share her negative thoughts with others--
我了解 Banias。她是个乐观的人。她很积极。她甚至不想把负面想法分享给别人——
Hello?
喂？
--even when she's fearful. Like--
——即使是在她感到恐惧的时候。比如——
Hello?
喂？
This is my space, Banias. Please go away.
这是我的空间，Banias。请走开。
No!
不！
I'm talking. She's someone who loves life and loves to play and loves to--
我在说话。她是个热爱生活、热爱游戏、热爱——
It's almost like she's willing it. She's willing-- She's using all of her force to will life into being easier than it is.
这几乎就像是她在用意志实现愿望。她在用她所有的力量希望生活比实际情况更容易。
Yeah. Yeah. And she always trying to change the mood for the people to make them feel optimistic.
是的。是的。她总是试图改变人们的心情，让他们感到乐观。
Hi.
你好。
Hi, Banias.
你好，Banias。
Hi. Hi, Chana. How are you?
你好。你好，Chana。你好吗？
That was basically the end of my conversation with Maram. As she did the first time around, Banias decided it was time for us to move on. My calls with Banias have grown more infrequent. The last time she called, I was in my office heading into a meeting. I was going to just say a quick hello, make sure she was OK.
这基本上就是我和 Maram 对话的结束。就像第一次一样，Banias 决定是我们该继续前进的时候了。我和 Banias 的通话变得越来越不频繁。最后一次她打电话时，我正在办公室准备去开会。我本来只想简单打个招呼，确保她平安。
Hello?
喂？
Hi, Banias. How are you?
你好，Banias。你好吗？
[BEEPING]
[提示音]
Hi.
你好。
Are you calling me on video?
你是在给我打视频电话吗？
Yes, I am.
是的，我是。
OK, hang on. Let's see.
好的，等一下。让我们看看。
Hi.
你好。
Oh, there you are. There you are. Hi.
哦，你在那儿。你在那儿。你好。
Hi. I'm watching a film. Do you want to see? It's called Home Alone.
你好。我正在看电影。你想看吗？叫《小鬼当家》。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
Do you know?
你知道吗？
I do.
我知道。
I love it. Would you like to watch with me? Would you like to watch?
我爱这部电影。你想和我一起看吗？你想看吗？
I paused, looked at my watch, saw my coworkers heading to the meeting room, and decided to go ahead with her agenda.
我停顿了一下，看了看手表，看到同事们正走向会议室，决定还是顺着她的议程来。
Oh, let's see it together.
哦，我们一起看吧。
OK, for a few minutes.
好的，看几分钟。
Oh. Oh, my God. I want to cover myself. It's so cold here. Oh. OK. Oh, my God. I'm here.
哦。哦，天哪。我想把自己裹起来。这里太冷了。哦。好的。哦，天哪。我在呢。
OK.
好的。
She's under the covers with her phone and her laptop in purple pajamas. She's sitting on her mattress on the floor. And she's pointing the phone at her screen, so we can watch together.
她穿着紫色睡衣，带着手机和笔记本电脑躲在被子里。她坐在地板上的床垫上。她把手机对准屏幕，这样我们就可以一起看。
I'm covering myself in the tent.
我正躲在帐篷里的被子里。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
Oh. Here. Do you see?
哦。这里。你看到了吗？
Yeah, I can see.
是的，我看到了。
Oh!
哦！
Hey! Shoplifter!
嘿！小偷！
Oh, my God! Oi!
哦，天哪！哎哟！
Of course, Banias is a vocal movie watcher.
当然，Banias 是个爱发声的电影观众。
Who is he?
他是谁？
She has a running commentary on the characters, repeats English words that are new to her, explains the movie.
她对角色有持续的评价，重复着对她来说是新学的英语单词，解释电影。
He's now skating on the ice. They leave him alone. But he's happy, happy.
他现在在冰上滑冰。他们把他独自留下了。但他很高兴，很高兴。
Would you be happy if that happened?
如果那种事发生在你身上，你会高兴吗？
Yes! I'm free!
会！我自由了！
You would?
你会吗？
I will shout in the home, I'm free! I'm free!
我会对着家里大喊，我自由了！我自由了！
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
We're the Wet Bandits. You're sick. You know that? Really silly!
我们是“湿匪”。你有病吗？你知道吗？真的很蠢！
Really silly.
真的很蠢。
That's it! That's a sick thing to say!
就是这样！说这种话真有病！
McCaulley Caulkin-- who I'd forgotten is also eight years old in this movie-- is walking home, crosses a driveway, just as the two burglars, Joe Pesci and the other guy, pull out in their van, screech to a halt, and McCaulley Caulkin does his blonde surprise face.
麦考利·卡尔金——我忘了他在电影里也是八岁——正走回家，穿过车道，两个窃贼——乔·佩西和另一个人——开着货车冲出来，猛地刹住车，麦考利·卡尔金露出了他那副标志性的金发惊讶表情。
Hey, watch out!
嘿，小心！
[TIRES SQUEALING]
[轮胎摩擦声]
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Oh. [GIGGLES] That's so funny.
哦。[咯咯笑] 真有趣。
Hey, hey! You gotta watch out for traffic, son, you know?
嘿，嘿！你得注意交通，孩子，你知道吗？
Sorry.
抱歉。
Santa don't visit the funeral home, little buddy.
圣诞老人不去殡仪馆，小伙子。
OK, OK. Merry Christmas.
好的，好的。圣诞快乐。
I do like the Christmas design.
我确实很喜欢圣诞风格。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
I really like this movie. And when they travel to New York-- oh, where do you live?
我真的很喜欢这部电影。当他们上次去纽约旅行时——哦，你住在哪？
I live in New York. That's where I live.
我住在纽约。我就住在那里。
In the New York?
纽约？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Yes. Kevin's family travels there last time. You live in New York?
是的。凯文的家人上次去那里旅游。你住在纽约？
Mm-hmm, I do.
嗯哼，是啊。
Oh, I want to tell you something. What about this statue that you have?
哦，我想告诉你一件事。你那个雕像怎么样？
The Statue of Liberty?
自由女神像？
Yes! It's in New York.
是的！就在纽约。
Yeah.
是啊。
You see it? I want to see it!
你看到了吗？我想看看它！
Oh, yeah. I don't see it right now, but I see it-- I see it pretty often.
哦，是的。我现在没看到它，但我经常——我经常看到它。
When you are out of your house, you see it?
当你离开家时，能看到它吗？
Yeah, when I go--
是的，当我去——
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
--when I go to work, sometimes I can see it.
——当我去工作时，有时能看到它。
Oh, I want to go to work with you to see it. I'd love to.
哦，我想和你一起去工作看看它。我很想看看。
Banias, the houses there in that part of the movie, does it look anything like Gaza?
Banias，电影里那部分出现的房子，看起来像加沙吗？
No.
不像。
How is it different?
有什么不同？
No. Gaza is more beautiful.
不。加沙更漂亮。
Even now?
现在也是吗？
Yes, even now, and every time.
是的，现在也是，一直都很漂亮。
Two days earlier, Israeli airstrikes hit Al Aqsa Hospital in Deir Balah, right near Banias's apartment. The hospital was surrounded by tents filled with displaced people sleeping. The airstrikes caused a fire that ripped through those tents. I'd seen Maram sharing images and videos of people sleeping in the tents burned alive.
两天前，以色列空袭了代尔拜拉赫的阿克萨医院，就在 Banias 公寓附近。医院周围挤满了流离失所者居住的帐篷。空袭引发的大火烧毁了那些帐篷。我看到 Maram 分享了人们在帐篷里被活活烧死的照片和视频。
I wondered if Banias had seen those images, but I didn't ask. Instead, we watched this Christmas movie. We watched Kevin trick the burglars into thinking his family is home by staging a fake party in his house.
我不知道 Banias 是否看到了那些照片，但我没问。相反，我们看了这部圣诞电影。我们看着凯文通过 staging 一个假的家庭派对，让窃贼们以为他的家人在家。
Oh, my. Oh, my God. What's that?
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。那是什么？
Any war is a series of plot points. Even in an ongoing war, a never-ending and no-longer-new war, we track its progress by the worst moments. I kept calling Banias with this expectation, waiting for the story of the war as I was understanding it, to somehow intersect with her life as she was experiencing it.
任何战争都是一系列的情节点。即使是在一场持续的、无休止且不再新鲜的战争中，我们也通过最糟糕的时刻追踪它的进展。我一直在怀着这种期望给 Banias 打电话，等待着战争的故事——就像我所理解的那样——以某种方式与她所经历的生活交叉。
I kept imagining, dreading, that one of those moments will break through, that something bad will happen to Banias. One of those horrible plot points will become her plot point.
我不断想象，甚至恐惧，那其中的一个时刻会突破防线，Banias 会发生不好的事。那些可怕的情节点之一会成为她的情节点。
But something bad is happening to Banias. This is the plot point for her. She's sitting under the covers with no electricity, no heat, winter approaching. Banias has not been in school for over a year. She has no home. She has a cough, and there is no medicine.
但坏事确实正在发生在 Banias 身上。这就是她的情节点。她躲在没有电、没有暖气的被子里，冬天即将来临。Banias 已经一年多没有上学了。她没有家。她咳嗽，没有药。
Her friends have scattered. Some of them are dead. Her relatives are all over. Some of them are dead. She's eating canned beans, instead of burgers. She's finding glass in her brother's head. This is her life. This is the story she has to narrate.
她的朋友们四散奔逃。其中一些已经死了。她的亲戚遍布各处。一些也死了。她吃着罐装豆子，而不是汉堡。她在弟弟的头上发现玻璃碎片。这就是她的生活。这就是她必须叙述的故事。
Do you want to see where he will go? I don't know exactly where he will go.
你想看他会去哪吗？我不知道他具体会去哪。
He's hiding.
他在躲藏。
OK, Banias, I'm going to go.
好的，Banias，我要走了。
Oh? Do you want to leave? I want to continue this movie and then go to sleep.
哦？你想离开了吗？我想看完这部电影然后睡觉。
OK, sleep well. I'll talk to you soon.
好的，晚安。我们很快再聊。
Where are you? Are you still here?
你在哪？你还在吗？
I'm here.
我在。
Hello? Hello?
喂？喂？
I'm here.
我在。
Are you still here?
你还在吗？
Yes, I am.
是的，我在。
We have a couple minutes left in this episode, and I have a small update. Recently, Banias's family moved-- not far-- an apartment a couple miles from Deir Balah, where they've been staying. The new place is less crowded. There's more privacy for her family. It has trees outside and a refrigerator-- that doesn't work, but still. The apartment is quiet, temporary.
这一集节目还剩下几分钟，我有一个简短的更新。最近，Banias 的一家搬了家——离得不远——搬到了代尔拜拉赫几英里外的一处公寓。新地方没那么拥挤。她的家人有了更多的隐私。外面有树，还有一个冰箱——虽然不能用，但还是有的。公寓很安静，是暂时的。
And it's not home. Banias knows she can't go home to the north of Gaza, where she's from. She knows her home was destroyed. She's seen pictures of her neighborhood exploded, on fire. And she's seen video of the empty space where her house was, the small mountains of rubble.
那不是家。Banias 知道她回不去加沙北部了，那是她的家乡。她知道她的家被毁了。她看过照片，她附近的社区被炸毁、起火了。她看过视频，那是她家曾经所在的地方，成了一座小小的瓦砾山。
The gray couch with yellow cushions that she sat on after school, the chandelier her mother chose, the mirror by the door, the teacups and trays filled with treats, her new reimagined big girl bedroom with an Elsa bedspread, her desk, the pink moon they hung on the ceiling-- all of that is somewhere in that pile of rubble. All of that is there in the north of Gaza, their life.
她放学后坐的黄色坐垫灰色沙发、她母亲挑选的吊灯、门口的镜子、装满点心的茶杯和托盘、她那间重新装扮的拥有 Elsa 床单的大女孩卧室、她的书桌、他们挂在天花板上的粉色月亮——所有这些都在那堆瓦砾里的某个地方。所有这些都在加沙北部，他们的生活。
But the north of Gaza has been transformed. There were about a million people living in northern Gaza when the war started, over 270,000 homes. Everyone was told to leave, to go south. Most people did. And now those people are separated from the north of Gaza by a wide militarized zone that they cannot cross.
但加沙北部已经变样了。战争开始时，约有一百万人住在加沙北部，有超过 27 万户房屋。每个人都被告知离开，去南部。大多数人照做了。而现在，这些人被一个宽阔的军事化区域与加沙北部隔开，他们无法穿越。
Israel has been building and fortifying this military zone for the last few months. It cuts right across Gaza, splits Gaza in two, completely separating the north of Gaza, where Banias is from, from the south of Gaza, where she's been displaced to. This military zone is called the Netzarim Corridor. It has a constant military presence, and it's big, around 20 square miles. It takes up more than 12% of the entire territory of Gaza.
以色列过去几个月一直在建造和加固这个军事区域。它直接穿过加沙，将加沙一分为二，完全将 Banias 来自的加沙北部与她被流离失所到的南部隔开。这个军事区域被称为“内扎里姆走廊”（Netzarim Corridor）。它有常驻的军事存在，而且规模很大，约有 20 平方英里。它占据了整个加沙地带超过 12% 的面积。
In order to build it, Israel cleared out a wide stretch of land, demolished hundreds of buildings, from the Israeli border all the way to the ocean. And in that space, Israel installed checkpoints and paved roads and flags and water lines and cell phone towers. It looks like something you'd put in place if you're planning to stay a while.
为了建造它，以色列清理了一大片土地，拆毁了数百座建筑，从以色列边境一直延伸到海洋。在这个空间里，以色列安装了检查站、铺设了道路、插上了旗帜、铺设了水管和手机信号塔。它看起来像是如果你计划留在这里一段时间会做的事情。
A former chief of staff of the Israeli military has called the emptying out of the north of Gaza an ethnic cleansing. He said, quote, "the land is being cleared of Arabs." Human Rights Watch, Oxfam, Amnesty International have all called what is happening in Gaza an ethnic cleansing, or a genocide.
一位以色列军方前参谋长称加沙北部的清空行动为“种族清洗”。他说，引用，“土地正在被清理，没有阿拉伯人。”人权观察、乐施会、国际特赦组织都称加沙正在发生的事情为种族清洗或种族灭绝。
Israel denies this, and the Israeli military sent me a statement calling the charge of ethnic cleansing entirely baseless. It says it's working to dismantle Hamas's military infrastructure and is adhering to its obligations under international law.
以色列否认了这一点，以色列军方给我发了一份声明，称种族清洗的指控完全毫无根据。声明称，它正在致力于拆除哈马斯的军事基础设施，并遵守其在国际法下的义务。
The people who remained in the north and never left are under siege, with increasingly limited food and medical care. The UN says children are, quote, "as ever, the first and most to suffer."
留在北部没走的人正处于围困之中，食物和医疗护理日益匮乏。联合国表示，儿童是“一如既往，首当其冲且受害最深的人”。
So this latest move for Banias's parents, it feels like a new phase. It's a move from "I can't believe it's gone on this long" to "this is going to keep going on." For Banias, it's more of the same, more temporary, more displacement, displacement that looks pretty likely to last most, if not all, of her childhood.
所以对于 Banias 的父母来说，这次最新的搬迁感觉像是一个新阶段。这是一个从“不敢相信这会持续这么久”到“这会一直持续下去”的转变。对于 Banias 来说，这更多的是一样的东西，更多的临时性，更多的流离失所——这种流离失所看起来极有可能持续她童年的大部分甚至全部时光。
Today's episode was produced by Valerie Kipnis and edited by Laura Starecheski. The people who put together today's show are Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Henry Larson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
今天的节目由 Valerie Kipnis 制作，Laura Starecheski 编辑。参与制作今天节目的人员有 Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Henry Larson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker 和 Diane Wu。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor, David Kestenbaum. Executive editor, Emanuele Berry. Welcome to the world, Elias Berryman-Chace.
我们的执行编辑是 Sarah Abdurrahman。高级编辑 David Kestenbaum。执行主编 Emanuele Berry。欢迎来到这个世界，Elias Berryman-Chace。
Special thanks this week to Hany Hawasly, Bethel Habte, Khalil Sayegh, Nabil Shawkat, Mona Chalabi, Rachel Lissy, Rebecca Vitali-DeCola, Claire Garmirian, and Becky Smith with Save the Children, Shaina Lowe and Camilla Lodi with the Norwegian Refugee Council, Tania Hary with Gisha, Amy Walters and the wonderful Al Jazeera podcast The Take, Corey Scher with the City University of New York, Jamon Van Den Hoek with Oregon State University and the UN Satellite Center.
本周特别感谢 Hany Hawasly, Bethel Habte, Khalil Sayegh, Nabil Shawkat, Mona Chalabi, Rachel Lissy, Rebecca Vitali-DeCola, Claire Garmirian 以及来自“救助儿童会”的 Becky Smith, 来自挪威难民理事会的 Shaina Lowe 和 Camilla Lodi, 来自 Gisha 的 Tania Hary, Amy Walters 和精彩的半岛电视台播客 The Take, 纽约城市大学的 Corey Scher, 俄勒冈州立大学和联合国卫星中心（UNOSAT）的 Jamon Van Den Hoek。
Dr. Iman Farajallah's book that focuses on the experiences of children in Gaza in particular is called My Life is a War. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
Iman Farajallah 博士关于加沙儿童经历的著作名为《我的生活即战争》。《美国生活》由公共广播交流协会（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。
To become a This American Life partner, which gets you bonus content, ad-free listening, and hundreds of our favorite episodes of the show right in your podcast feed, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. Ira will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
想要成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴，获取奖励内容、无广告收听和在你的播客订阅源中直接获取数百集我们最喜爱的节目，请访问 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。该链接也在节目注释中。我是 Chana Joffe-Walt。Ira 将在下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
So this whole episode of the show is all conversations with you. And--
所以这整期节目都是和你进行的对话。而且——
OK! That's great. I will be the star of Gaza.
好的！那太棒了。我会成为加沙的明星。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I'll be a star. I'll be a star. By the way, the mushroom, too, wants to be the mushroom star of Gaza. Mushroom is joining us in the conversation.
我会成为明星。我会成为明星。顺便说一下，蘑菇也想成为加沙的明星蘑菇。蘑菇正在加入我们的对话。
Hi, mushroom.
你好，蘑菇。
Hi, Chana. I'm joining you to the conversation--
你好，Chana。我正在加入你们的对话——
Do you want--
你想——
--to be the mushroom star in Gaza.
——成为加沙的明星蘑菇。